[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire pour une émission consacrée
au cinéaste même que kassovitz et son
film le plus célèbre la haine qui fête
son 25ème anniversaire il est ressorti
en salles depuis le 5 août en version
restaurée 4k et l'on va voir qu'il est
toujours d'actualité mais d'abord notre
époque qu'est ce qui la caractérise ce
début de 21e siècle nous habitent nos
invités ont l'habitude de répondre en
images voici celle que vous nous avez
apporté mathieu kassovitz ce sont des
images qui bougent on va les voir tout
de suite alors expliquez nous de quoi
s'agit-il
c'est pas une image qui caractérise
notre époque mais c'est une image qui
caractérise notre époque un nous un
groupe qu'on représente que ces deux
personnes là sur le sur le la grue cjr
el-adli qui viennent de montfermeil et
et qui ont commencé leur carrière enfin
leur carrière leur aventure avec une
photo très spécifique de la dgi qui
tenait une caméra comme si c'était une
juifs le rappeler fait réalisateur des
misérables les érables et dix ans plus
tard ils sont devenus tous les deux deux
artistes reconnus dans le monde entier
et ce qu'ils ont fait là sur cette image
là c'est remettre des yeux trahir
travaille beaucoup sur le regard des
gens et ils ont ils donnent un regard et
donne un regard aux gens qui n'auront
pas et
là on voit les yeux de la jeunesse sur
une barque qui va être détruite bientôt
donc tout un symbole de ce que ça
représente de la façon dont les deux
sociétés peuvent se regarder l'une et
l'autre les et favoriser les défavorisés
et voir ce qu'ils peuvent en faire et
ils ont réussi à faire quelque chose ils
viennent de là c'est vraiment des mecs
du quartier ils ont réussi quelque chose
d'absolument incroyable les misérables
d'ailleurs ait eu un succès un peu
similaire à celui de l'aisne 25 ans
après comment avez vous trouvé ce film
très intéressant avec la même énergie
que que je demande moi en tant que
spectateur pour pour les films que je
veux voir quels qu'ils soient je
trouvais qu'ils avaient enfin il ya une
affiliation tellement évidente avec la
haine que jean que le quai en être fier
donc donc je suis avec eux à 100% alors
justement revenons sur la n25 ans après
on s'en souvient comme d'un film sur la
banlieue mais c'était avant tout un film
sur les bavures policières ça commençait
d'ailleurs et ça se terminait par une
bavure policière
elle se livre un film sur les jeunes de
banlieue jusque les banlieues ouais
c'était sûr c'était essayer d' humaniser
les jeunes de quartiers qui à l'époque
n'était pas connu du tout mais c'est
vrai que le point de départ c'est quand
même une bavure policière et est
d'ailleurs le film commence par départ
des manifestations par des émeutes par
de la violence et ont l'impression que
25 ans après quand le film ressort on
est exactement dans la même situation
je rappelle qu' il ya eu la faire
charger floyd juste avant l'été puis les
manifestations pour pour adama traoré
on a l'impression que rien n'a changé
c'est aussi votre impression ajoutez à
ça surtout toutes les manifestations
contre les les g7 les g20 toutes les
manifestations pour la sur l'écologie
sur les et les problèmes de taxes dans
les toutes ces toutes ces manifestations
que le peuple soulève quotidiennement
n'était pas là et à 25 ans donc se
rajoute à
à ce problème qui n'est pas réglée
toujours que les problèmes but brute de
brutalité policière qui ne sera jamais
réglé on demande parce que s qui n'est
plus de brutalité policière on demande
juste ce qu'il y ait du respect de la
reconnaissance de ces problèmes pour
qu'on puisse les régler c'est tout ça
c'est ajouter aujourd'hui l'époque et
plus beaucoup plus intense que celle de
l'époque on a l'impression qu'on en
n'avait jamais autant parlé qu'on en a
parlé au mois de juin au moins de 2 au
début du mois de juillet ouais mais vous
savez c'est bête à dire mais le film dit
un truc qui d'une phrase qui est très
connu qui dit l'important c'est pas la
chute c'est l'atterrissage
on nous prévenait moi je me souviens que
quand j'avais 20 ans nous prévenait à la
télévision nous disait faites attention
parce que dans trente ans et
l'atterrissage au niveau écologique
il va y avoir des problèmes dont on va
aller on va si on ne règle pas
maintenant on va avoir des problèmes on
a essayé les régler on a on a participé
à ça on a peut-être poussé un petit peu
l'échéance mais on est en plein dans
cette dans ces problèmes-là donc
aujourd'hui pour moi le problème il est
plus sûr la brutalité policière qui est
un problème qui fait qui fait partie de
la société qui ne sera jamais réglé
encore une fois il est vraiment sur le
cerveau un problème de société
dans sa généralité mais on le voit 25
ans plus tard que on est dans cette
d'atterrissage et que le sol se
rapproche et on n'a aucun moyen de on
n'a pas de parachute
d'ailleurs c'était la phrase jusqu'ici
tout va bien qui revenait dans le film
pour c'est que jusqu'ici tout va bien
encore non moi j'ai jamais pensé que
jusqu'ici tout allait bien moi je
pensais que c'est évidemment du sarcasme
cette phrase je pense pas que jusqu'ici
tout va bien enfin si mais vraiment dans
la dans la tête de quelqu'un qui tombe
d'un immeuble de 50 étages
silas et de philosophie tout va bien
jusqu'au moment de l'atterrissage mais
je propose et ça sert à rien le problème
c'est que ça sert à rien de paniquer la
chute elle est là elle est irrémédiable
et il faut juste gérer l'atterrissage
donc est-ce qu'on va réussir à le gérer
ou est-ce qu'on va se laisser
complètement année ça j'en serais l
époque de la sortie de la haine en 1995
vous parliez de la mort d'un jeune homme
noir tué par un policier dans un
commissariat du 18e il s'appelait mac os
mais mbh au mollet
le il avait été accusé d'avoir volé des
cigarettes il était mort tué d'une balle
de revolver par un policier en plein
commissariat le policier a été condamné
à huit ans de prison et donc à l'époque
on condamnait les policiers bien sûr je
bon après on peut se demander sur la
vraiment ce que ce que enfin va pas
rentrer un des problèmes de justice mais
oui la justice est rendue en france on a
on a une on a une justice assez solide
mais c'est pas parce qu'il ya des choses
évidentes comme ça sur lesquels on a
réussi à gueuler on a gueulé tellement
fort que la justice a été obligé de se
rendre à l'évidence on peut pas tirer
dans la tête d'un jeune homme qui est
menotté dans un commissariat et s'en
sortir c'est impossible
donc c'est normal il ya il y à cette
saison on a en france contrairement aux
états unis ce sentiment de ne pas rendre
de jus que la justice est rendue
mais on a aussi asa traoré ses frères ça
fait quatre ans qu'ils se battent pour
une vie pour une une chose absolument
tragique qui s'est passé qui améliore
ses deux autres frères en prison qu'il
amène l as eu à se battre comme une
lionne tous les jours pour que la
justice soit rétablie sur un problème
qui est évident et dont tout le monde et
dont tout le monde devrait être d'accord
et je ne comprends pas pourquoi on
n'accepte pas que les gens fassent des
erreurs qu'on les punisse pour leurs
erreurs parce qu'ils sont responsables
comme en commun comme un conducteur qui
renverse quelqu'un dans la rue on
accepte de faire de pouvoir se faire
renverser dans la rue et éventuellement
c'est pour son sort dans la rue on prend
ces risques là on accepte aussi que dans
une confrontation avec des policiers on
puisse on puisse prendre un mauvais coup
on peut l'accepter mais on peut pas
accepter que ce ne soit pas reconnu que
ce ne soit pas pris en compte et que ce
soit pas réglé et c est le problème
depuis le début nous on demande juste
que il ya du respect pour les victimes
du respect pour les gens qui subissent
et que et que et c'est ça la justice
c'est juste le respect si un seul
respect là il n'y aura pas de problème
sur les problèmes sur les autres
problèmes on est tous d'accord sur des
accidents et je pense que même à ça
traoré même ses frangins axa aurait
accepté si la sicile la gendarmerie leur
avait dit qu'effectivement voilà ce qui
s'est passé on a tout essayé pour sauver
votre frère malheureusement
c'est mal passé il est mort il y aurait
peut-être une journée d'émeutes mais
cette histoire ne serait toujours pas en
tête des balades dans l'actualité
aujourd'hui la haine c'était aussi un
réquisitoire contre les médias vous les
accusez y est plus ou moins d'attiser la
haine
vous pensez que c'est toujours le cas
aujourd'hui non non la haine n'a pas je
ne dis jamais tu es un vin film fera
t-il sur les médias le fils âgé c'est le
film que j'ai fait en réaction ensuite à
la façon dont j'ai pris les médias dans
la gueule pour la m oui c'est un film
anti médias mais j'étais pas du tout il
y à une scène dans le film ou voir les
acteurs répondre à des des cameramans
qui viennent qui ont les uns essaient de
les interviews depuis leur voiture mais
c'était le cas à l'époque et c'était le
cas moi quand je venais de tourner dans
la cité on voulait pas de caméra parce
que les caméras étaient associés à des
gens qui venaient chercher la merde en
fait tout simplement
il y avait aucune connaissance de des
jeunes de banlieue le seul d'un seul
dénominateur commun qui ont trouvé dans
tous les médias c'était les racailles
voilà on en avait peur quand on est mené
sur paris on avait un fantasme et sur ce
qui se passait dans les travers et moi
mon but était comme c'était mes amis
j'essaie de leur donner un petit peu
d'humanité pour qu'on se dise mais s'ils
sont victimes c'est pour être nos
enfants aussi
et il faut une justice pour ces gens là
c'est pas les animaux c'était un truc
très simple c'est pas du tout un truc
contre les médias ne me contre la police
réellement c'était vraiment un
parce qu'on peut pas accuser une
personne de à travers l'erreur d'une
personne tout une toute une congrégation
malgres malgré tout on veut que le reste
que ses collègues le dénonce c'est ça la
gc ca quiconque dans le monde et le film
et parle de ça il ya une scène où on
voit comment deux policiers torture ces
jeunes hommes et que y'en a un jeune qui
éclaire qui les regardent et qui va qui
va devoir prendre la décision est ce
qu'il va devenir comme eux ou est-ce
qu'il va est ce qu'il va démissionner
cdc c'est tout une prise de conscience
c'est ce film là était était fait pour
ça et voilà et 25 ans plus tard il a il
raisonne toujours malheureusement
parlant de la paranoïa que créé à
l'époque il sans doute au score
aujourd'hui les jeunes de banlieue je
pense que vous vous souvenez de la fête
de la
au festival de cannes sauf que j ai
testé dans l'ancien palm beach qui avait
pas été restaurée c'était comme une
chance d'une ruine à la pointe de la
croisette et tout le monde avait peur
une descente des racailles entre
guillemets banlieue de de cannes et
d'ailleurs il y avait même je me
souviens d'un maître chien un chien
parce qu'on avait en avait on n'avait
pas quand le film est allé à cannes en
avait on avait mis tout l'argent dans le
film on n'avait pas de budget on savait
pas si le film allait marcher ou pas
donc il fallait faire une fête à cannes
et les fêtes à cannes c'est champagne le
saumon et nous on n'a ni les moyens ni
l'envié et donc on a trouvé ce lieu qui
était pas cher on a dit merguez frites
merguez frites ya même pas de frites
choix y avait juste merguez pain et et
la bière et et voilà comment on sait on
s'est retrouvé avec des gens soustrait
bien habillé marché un petit peu dans la
boue est très excité de côtoyer un petit
peu les jeunes qu'on avait fait venir
des potes de leur car il y avait des
mecs de marseille qui était venu donc
ils y avaient érigé un petit peu cette
chose à kiki c'est évidemment très bien
passé et qui donnait vraiment le ton du
film et qui nous a fait dire on est on
est pas on n'est pas dans le faux pour
annoncer que que ça peut bien se passer
entre ces deux communautés
le film est en noir et blanc voit les
images ici c'est un très très beau noir
et blanc mais il a été tourné en
couleurs est ce que ça veut dire que
vous avez changé d'avis ou pour obtenir
ce beau noir et blanc il fallait le
tourner en couleur pour en fait pour
pouvoir avoir l'argent des chaînes de
télévision il fallait pouvoir leur
fournir un film en couleur parce que la
télévision un film noir banque passerait
pas donc le deal était que si le film
était un succès en salles et passerait à
la télévision en couleur en noir et
blanc et si c'était pas un succès si
personne n'avait vu en salle il
passerait en couleur et c'est donc j'ai
accepté de tourner en pellicule couleur
mais on s'en est servi pour justement
obtenir un noir et blanc beaucoup plus
plus intéressant que si on avait tourné
sur pellicule noir et blanc est-ce qu'il
est est ce qu'une version en couleur
existe jamais eu envie de les saisir
elle existe dans sa version négative
dans son original l'original
qui est sorti qui est dans un dans une
cave quelque part protéger est en
couleur ce serait bizarre de le voir
j'imagine bien sorti quelques scènes qui
existe sur des dvd qu'on va peut-être
sortir on a un dvd qui ressort là nous
et quelques dans quelques semaines pour
le 25e anniversaire thiem je refais des
commentaires on refait plein de choses
je sais plus exactement que je crois
qu'elle s'est extrait la en couleurs qui
sont à sa maman et j'imagine que c'est
pas la même ambiance
comment ça on couleurs ce film n'aurait
vous savez c'est comme si vous regardez
les photos de brassaï et que vous
essayez de les imaginer en couleurs
c'est beaucoup moins ou cartier bresson
c'est beaucoup moins intéressant tout
d'un coup parce que vous êtes vous êtes
un bon je peux pas dire ça de leur
travail
je suis très intéressant aussi en
couleurs mais il faut tout qu'on connaît
d'eux c'est ce qui est intéressant dans
l'ambulance et qu'on focalise sur un
sujet on n'est pas pollué par le reste
de l'image qui est reine de
l'information nous on a pas besoin et
pour gérer la couleur c'est très très
difficile et en photo c'est un petit peu
plus facile puisque le résultat final
doit elle peut être plus facilement
travailler mais on en aurait en cinéma
c'est très difficile quand on n'a pas
d'argent de faire de la bonne couleur
c'est un film très musical très rythmé
est ce que vous voulez vraiment faire
une comédie musicale aujourd'hui je fais
une comédie musicale qui va sortir en
2022 pour les pauvres dans les zénith de
france ont fait un très gros projet
qu'on a lancé il ya six mois et qui est
qui est très excitant qui m'excite
énormément parce que j'avais conçu la
haine comme moi je viens du hip hop j'ai
grandi avec le rap est donc j'ai conçu
ce film comme une série de deux morceaux
qui pourrait être indépendants les uns
des autres et qui parlent chacun d'un
sujet qui amène à la fin à une
conclusion sur les dix dernières
secondes du film et qui chaque chaque
scène peut parler d'un sujet différent
et pour être racontée en chansons
quasiment pour être apl pour être
mise en valeur d'une manière plus plus
musical et plus plus lyrique et j'ai
essayé de le faire même quand on a sorti
le disque du film parce qu'il ya pas de
musique dans le film il ya une musique
qui est qui sort des autoradios et qui
sort de des fenêtres mais ya pas de
musique du film et on a sorti une bande
originale de musique inspirée par le
film et j'avais dit à tous les groupes
essayons de trouver de toi prends cette
scène toi prends cette scène toi prends
cette sem et à travers toutes les
servent à les remettre en ordre et on
arrache toute l'histoire du film chacun
vous de faire ce qu'il voulait à
l'époque séance et je ne compte donc on
a ils ont fait leur truc mais moi j'ai
dessus tout le reste est dans le regret
de ne pas pouvoir mettre en musique
cette histoire là mais alors ça va se
passer si c'est une comédie musicale ça
va être avec eux j'imagine des gens qui
vont scratch et en direct toute façon un
petit peu en direct boomer de raconter
le truc oui il y aura du scratch
il y aura des hip hop non il ya surtout
des gens de talent vous avez par exemple
les danseurs en france on est on est les
meilleurs danseurs au monde
on va rentrer aux jeux olympiques on
danse et si on regarde ce que font les
arcs les athlètes de en break
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose
d'absolument ccc même les athlètes
officiels des jeux olympiques de hull
d'arçons de tous à son nom est étonné et
apprennent de leurs techniques donc
c'est des gens qui c'est une culture qui
vient de la rue qu'à 30 ans d'âge et qui
est qui a complètement changé le monde
voilà donc moi j'essaie de redonner un
petit peu
hommage à cette culture là il le faire à
travers ce projet qui n'est plus
purement un truc sur les bavures
policières mais qu'est-ce qui est là sur
la même histoire mais qui est vraiment
un sujet sur la demande de respect des
petits envers les grands quoi voilà vous
trouvez à l'époque influencé par spike
lee vous en souvenez métis par exemple
votre premier film on l'avait comparé à
nola darling n'en fait qu'à sa tête le
premier film de spike lee dans les deux
cas c'était une femme qui avait
plusieurs amants même appelé lola
voilà exactement totalement assumé on a
dit ensuite que la m c'était votre 12h
right thing qui ont arrêté de le dire
après alors d'abord est ce que est ce
que l'influencé est allé jusqu'à laine
nola darling oui effectivement parce que
à l'époque de métis quand j'étais jeune
et que je faisais je voulais faire du
cinéma j'ai vu deux films qui m'ont
marqué qui m'ont dit je peux réaliser
moi aussi j'ai vu le dernier combat de
luc besson
ouais quand j'avais 17 18 ans qui m'a
tellement tout premier film son tout
premier film et c'est un film en noir et
blanc justement qui est fait avec la
main entre copains et qu'un film de
science-fiction et qui est ce qui a
lancé sa carrière mais qui est un film
étonnant vraiment étonnant au niveau de
la mise en scène au niveau de la
technique au niveau de l'intelligence de
production comment arriver à faire un
film sans argent il est très jeune à
l'époque très jeune il avait 23 ans 24
heures et puis comme j'étais dans le hip
hop est un film qui est sorti aussi à
l'époque s'appelait nodar ming n'en fait
qu'à sa tête chez le dollar a vite été
réalisé par un jeune réalisateur qui
était spike lee et qui était un film
complètement libre et très inspiré de la
nouvelle vague française très inspiré de
godard très inspiré de tout le cinéma
français dont je viens aussi et de woody
allen de tout 7,7 de tous ces artistes
qui font mon kim qui ont fais mon cinéma
à moi et j'ai retrouvé là tout d'un coup
ce synthétiser un petit peu la culture
que j'aime qui n'étaient pas représentés
au cinéma du tout le hip hop est un
cinéma vraiment cinéma de de scorsese et
tout ça donc j'ai quand j'ai vu ce film
là je me suis dit waouw samassa j'ai
envie de faire ça et moi je vivais avec
cette jeune fille et j'ai toujours posé
je me suis toujours posé la question
est-ce qu'elle préférait pas être avec
elle et des métis qu'est ce qui se passe
si elle se retrouve entre un noir et un
blanc
voilà bien trash et benoît raft et
hubert koundé c'était vrai et gégé
j'essaie de 2
donc 2 je me suis inspiré donnant la
darling dans le dans l'état d'esprit
mais je les plus politisés j'essayais de
la mer un niveau qui plus est est sur
notre société aussi je n'ai pas laissé
je n'ai pas américanisé ou quoi que ce
soit donc c'est un très joli film que je
trouve que j'ai fait qu'un fils de
famille vraiment oui et c'est la mère de
votre fille et sa mère de l'infini et
spike lee par la suite il ya eu il ya eu
malcolm x après spike lee moi j'aime pas
trop ce pas avec les après je trouve
qu'il a une
après ces deux films là j'étais très
tenu à l'écart des films comme malcom x
monde et plus j'ai trouvé ça mais moi je
pense que enfin je pense
j'affirme que 100% d'un film et dans
l'écran l'écran est rectangulaire si
vous laissez 2 cm à l'extérieur le
spectateur ne voit pas on peut suggérer
on peut faire plein de choses mais il
faut faire attention à ce qu'on met dans
l'écran est par exemple dans malcom x 6
enfin peut-être que ces boues fantasme
mais si je me souviens bien par exemple
tous les noirs sont tous les blancs sont
méchant le seul blanc qui attaque et
sympa qui amène une bonne nouvelle un
moment c'est un docteur et il n'est pas
blanc il est métis et c'est déjà une
pour l'époque c'est étonnant qu'un
métier soit puisse être docteur je
trouve qu'il est parti dans un truc très
partisan et j'en ai parlé à cevital a
dans les médias et il a entendu depuis
on s'aime pas beaucoup mais on s'est
retrouvés grâce à gières justement et on
s'est serré la main il ya pas longtemps
c'est fou comme comme la haine à
l'époque tranchait avec le reste de la
production française
il faut se souvenir qu'à l'époque la
production française c'est des films qui
s'intitule la fille seule je m'ennuie je
suis à table tous les films d'ailleurs
avancé se passer à table je suis demandé
si c'était pour ça pour ça qu'il n'y
avait aucune scène à table dans
moi je moi je tiens mon père et ma mère
sont des cinéastes de talent et moins
éduquée à au travail bien fait et et à
la maîtrise de l'art cinématographe ses
terres que ces caméras là ce sont une
fenêtre sur un monde qu'on donne un
spectateur et on lui donne un rythme on
lui donne à lui donne une ambiance 108
dans le hall e on triche avec lui on
joue avec lui c'est un art on peut le
faire d'une manière très basique en
prenant une image simple et rajouter du
violon dessus pour faire pour amener de
l'émotion mais si on veut vraiment c'est
un peu un peu comme malienne stylo ou
manier le pinceau quand on est un
artiste manier la caméra c'est un vrai
un vrai travail et moi j'ai toujours été
admiratif de ça depuis que j'ai 12 ans
et depuis que je vois de cinéma des
autres donc moi quand j'ai décidé de
faire du cinéma je me suis dit je peux
faire ce genre de plan je peux
construire mon cinéma comme un comme un
arrêt pas comme juste un moyen de un
moyen de montrer quoi voilà donc donc
effectivement je me suis retrouvé dans
un cinéma français qui était très très
très enfermé dans ses dents sont dans
son dans ce qu'ils appelaient une
nouvelle vague encore le les enfants de
godard et truffaut mais moi j'étais
révoltée contre des films comme les
amants du pont-neuf de carax qui avait
eu des fonds de la ville de paris et de
jacques lang pour faire un film dont le
premier quart d'heure se passer dans un
véritable dépôt pour pour pour clochards
où on voit des choses terribles mais il
n'a pas pu faire le reste dans la suite
de la suite de sa film de son film dans
la rue il a été obligé de fabriquer un
faux pont à valenciennes qui a coûté 50
millions à l'époque pour faire un film
de merde avec des gens qui sont dans
tous les sens qui pensent que la vie ça
se passe comme ça enfin voilà donc ça ça
me révolte est d'accord c'est ça c'était
quand même très spectaculaire il avait
dû souvent on avait deux choses on est
des soirs un côté tu es dans ta cuisine
hockey soit à côté tu te prends pour le
tutu prend pour tu me donne des leçons
aux autres et tu
enfin n'ont même pas il n'y avait même
pas y avait que quatre axes qui faisait
sa série comique avec ce moyen là oui
parce qu'il était le chouchou de
l'intelligencia française et tout ça et
moi je trouvais ça je trouvais ça
dommage que que j'en fais avec toi
pourquoi tu prend 50 millions pour faire
un film sur des clochards cetc c'est
éthiquement mauvais tu devrais t'en
rendre compte
surtout quand tu ne suis le cinéma ce
qui est intéressant c'est d'avoir des
problèmes de ne pas pouvoir faire ce que
tu veux et d'être obligé trouver des
solutions ailleurs c'est ça qui fait des
bons films ça on n'a pas eu l'argent
qu'on voulait pour faire ce film
elle est jamais là c'était une vraie
guerre
larvée entre les tenants d'un certain
cinéma français qui était on détestait
le cinéma de genre quand jan kounen sort
doberman il se fait traiter de nazis
quand eric rochant sort les patriotes à
cannes le premier film qui traite de
l'espionnage
il se fait assassiner tous les films
ambitieux tous les films qui étaient
ambitieux un niveau visuel et qui a
essayé de changer un petit peu les les
dogmes de ce cinéma vérité qu'on avait
qui avait déjà 30 ans dans la vue tu
vois si tout cela on s'est pris jan
kounen gaspar noé tous ces gens là on
s'est pris des coups dans la gueule
parce qu'on sortait des sentiers battus
et on n'était pas du tout dans les trois
premiers films au générique de fin il ya
marqué ft cnc fuck de cmc parce qu'on a
jamais fait d'argent et senseo n'en
voulait pas on essaie de se débrouiller
sans eux parce qu'on voulait pas être
affilié à un gros un club qui qui qui se
complaît dans sa propre médiocrité parce
que malheureusement il n'y a pas
beaucoup de chefs-d'oeuvre qui sortait
de ce cinéma français là et puis moi je
viens d'une époque où à cas en 1980
c'était peur sur la ville
non mais c'est sa 13 ans tu regardes tu
voulais voir si la france était soit
peur sur la ville soit du film de garrel
j'aime bien les deux mais quand on
propose les dents de la mer en face ou
rencontre du troisième type on mean
street ou taxi driver bordel j'en tue
ton choix il est fait tout de suite quoi
perdre ce faire la ville vous aviez
vraiment ça non les jeunes bébel ah oui
quand j'ai bel babybel et un bébel est
un génie à tous les niveaux et puis et
puis j'aimais les verneuil jamais tout
ça bien sûr mais mais mais en tant que
jeune que jeune cinéaste en devenir
j'étais je ne pouvais pas aller voir ses
films et au cinéma on s'était c'était y
avait pas de cinéma réel derrière ces
films là ce que vous voulez voir c'était
c'était comment comment comment tu fais
pour faire un film avec un requin il ne
t'a pas de requins parce qu'aucun il
s'est cassé le milieu du film quand ça
sert les dents de la mer et en dépit de
tout ça au moment où la haine sort à
cannes il n'arrive pas vous assez signer
comme ils ont assassiné rochant poehl
peu de temps avant non parce que parce
que je vais dire pourquoi parce que le
film était hautement sympathique
al'inverse du film de roches ans qui
était qui est un film dur à voir avec un
film mais formidable quand une
formidable mais quand tu fais excite
s'il avait traité en comédie et ce
serait beaucoup plus accessible la m est
une comédie là la sympathie qu'on a pour
ces trois jeunes gens fait que c'est
difficile de leur cracher dessus et
c'est ça qu'on a réussi avec le film
c'est qu'on a réentendu ces trois mecs
sympathique
c'est pour ça que les dernières secondes
sont si tragique ces trois mecs sont
star n'est pas si tu enlèves les dix
dernières secondes c'est une comédie
pure et dure
ces trois mecs sont sympathiques et
pourtant on a l'impression qui en a
qu'un qui a réussi dans le cinéma
français par la suite c'est vincent
cassel saïd taghmaoui a dû émigrer aux
états unis et hubert koundé il continue
de tourner mais mais on le connaît plus
bah ouais
chacun son truc ils ont ils ont eu
chacun chacun est née saïd a décidé de
partir parce qu'il n'avait pas envie de
se battre ici pour faire des trucs
différents mais il a une carrière qui
fonctionne très bien là bas
vincent est là qu'un cliché et puis
hubert et la série 6 a laissé des gens
ils ont des personnalités ils font des
trucs on leur propose des choses par
moments il ya des opportunités qu'ils
saisissent donc ils ne saisissent pas
puis la vie et ce qu'elle est quoi donc
donc voilà ils ont chacun pris leur
chemin ont fait une pause mathieu
kassovitz on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
toujours avec mathieu kassovitz pour le
25e anniversaire de l' de la haine son
film le plus célèbre ressorti cet été en
version 4 cas après la haine vous allez
revenir à cannes avec un autre film
assassins que vous avez réalisé que vous
interprétez avec michel serrault et là
alors là ça se passe très très mal
un très très mal on considère le film
comme très violent mais évidemment ce
qui ne passe pas c'est que là vous vous
en prenez directement aux médias ce qui
était esquissé pour moi dans la bosse
dans l'aisne
là c'est le sujet du film prévu le coup
pas seulement on était on avait fait un
film contre les médias en réaction à ce
qui m'était arrivé sur la m6 m'arriver
sur la hem c'est que tous les tous les
gens à mes films nous avons et très peu
de mauvaise critique et j'ai fait des
tonnes d'interviews de gens qui étaient
très enthousiastes pour le film et qui
ne comprenaient pas forcément ce qu'on
voulait faire ou qui étaient plus amusé
par le côté starlette et paillettes du
truc sans comprendre le fond du film et
j'ai eu beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup à
faire
j'ai fait beaucoup d'interviews par
exemple avec les mecs du quartier à côté
de moi beaucoup et je et 90% des
questions étaient pour moi et même les
questions sur le quartier était pour moi
et je leur disais poser des questions
aux gens qui sont concernés ne me
demandez pas à moi si la police est
raciste demander à un noir ou un arabe
posez-moi les questions qui me concerne
moi je peux pas vous dire je peux vous
dire ce que mes copains subissent mais
comme ils sont là possédant la question
directement et j'ai vu beaucoup de
choses qui se sont passées on a eu des
des interviews qui sont plutôt venant
qui sont mal passées et le résultat
final et est aidé des gens disent très
contents qu'ils nous avaient fait un
petit un petit feuillet au milieu de
leurs trucs en disant apprenez à parler
de la banlieue avec le dictionnaire des
banlieues qui n'est pas adéquat qui
n'est pas intelligent qui n'est pas
éthique n'est pas et élégance et et ces
gens-là islam pensait avoir fait le bien
et j'étais obligée de leur expliquer
enfin puisque c'est que le journaliste
points et ça m'est arrivé plusieurs fois
et je me suis rendu compte que cette
perte des tic et surtout on était à une
époque en 97 95 ont commencé à ouvrir
les chaînes de télé du conseil avoir de
plus en plus de chaînes de télé on
commence à avoir plus de médias c'était
le début de l'internet et on commençait
à avoir
un espèce de commencer le zapping
commencé voilà c'est l'idée de ne pas
avoir le temps de s'asseoir et de
pouvoir passer d'une chaîne à l'autre et
d'accumuler autant d'informations en si
peu de temps
ce qui était complètement inconnu avant
parce que avant il fallait se lever on
avait trois chaînes et donc on avait une
chaîne ont résisté pendant deux heures
dessus là la capacité de changer de
sujet aussi vite je voyais aussi à
travers mes amis et les cette nouvelle
génération qui arrivait dans les
quartiers tous à une perte de 2,2
repères qui était aussi amenés par les
médias puisque les médias amène beaucoup
d'influx d'influx il faut arriver
nos cerveaux n'était pas encore équipés
surtout les cerveaux des jeunes n'est
pas encore équipé à discerner les choses
et j'ai vu beaucoup de choses par
exemple l'antisémitisme et beaucoup
donné enfin ce qu'on appelle
l'antisémitisme en france pour moi et
beaucoup n'est de de l'antisionisme qui
vient des images qu'on a vu de gaza d
intifada et de ces choses là qui ont été
mal expliqué à la télévision par les
médias et qui ont et qui ont fait que au
bout d'un moment les jeunes il est
associé les sionistes juifs et donc
l'association se faisait comme ça et
même chose de l'autre côté avec les
jeunes des quartiers qui étaient tous
considérés comme des racailles
donc c'est est il vraiment une époque
étonnante de devoir c'était le début de
ce qui nous arrive et là ce qui nous
arrive là cette espèce de sueur
technologie de et d'être obligé
d'alimenter ce qu'on crée une chaîne de
télévision il faut alimenter il faut
mettre des formes et des programmes et
vous avez été au début de beaucoup de
chaînes aussi vous savez à quel point la
qualité des programmes n'est pas autant
o'neill pas autant importante que le
fait de les faire pour pouvoir remplir
les tuyaux pour pouvoir vendre les pubs
au milieu et pour pouvoir juste remplir
les contrats
donc on se retrouvait avec avec beaucoup
de mauvais journalisme avec beaucoup de
contre vérités et c'était un petit peu
le début des faits que nous voilà et moi
je voulais montrer que si les
journalistes ne sont pas responsables de
la façon dont ils communiquent les
jeunes qui les lisent les générations
ensuite qu'ils vont l'élire vont
perdre cette même notion d'éthique de
travail de conscience de la vérité
d'essayer de se poser les bonnes
questions et j'ai fait un film qui parle
de trois générations de tueurs enfin un
vieux tueur qu'il ya une façon de faire
qui a eu un vrai travail de michel
serreau qui michel serrault et qui tombe
malade et qui prend un jeune tueur qui
lui pend ce qui peut faire le travail
mais qui a encore un petit peu de
conscience qui lui prend un jeune tueur
qui lui n'a plus aucune conscience voilà
donc c'est un film très dur très violent
qui commence par une scène de 20 minutes
ont torturé en tue un vieux monsieur de
70 ans
donc effectivement les gens commencent à
sortir de la salle très vite et j'étais
assez content parce que j'ai la première
la première critique du film est l
histoire le film le plus nul de
l'histoire du cinéma
deux ans après le film le plus génial de
l'histoire du cinéma j'étais assez
heureux donc voilà je skie avec drôle
c'est que michel serrault qui étaient
pas habitués au scandale cannois
non c'est pas un habitué de cannes en
façade était pas un habitué du festival
de cannes
hu jintao ils n'avaient pas vécu là elle
il n'était pas la grande mais j'étais
pas dans le dernier temps michel
serrault de michel serreau qui était un
catholique
oui très très très croyant et très il ya
comme un fait toute sa vie que des
conneries
en commençant par la cage aux folles
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que là à
ce moment là on voit qu'ils découvrent
ce que ces cascades balle cannois il
prend votre défense et mais il a l'air
complètement parce qu'il n'a jamais il
étonné que 0,32 autant de choses d'un
film parce qu'il n'a jamais fait de film
controverse silva café si elle fait la
cage aux folles aujourd'hui il ferait la
même chose que ce qu'il a fait sur la
haine c'est au bout d'un an c'est à dire
mais arrêtez de raconter des conneries
quoi tu vois à l'époque le problème est
homosexuel n'était pas que la société y
avait pas de problème donc le film est
sorti ça faisait partie de la culture tu
vois pas disons que le cinéma français à
l'époque avait une longue tradition se
moquer des homosexuels l écran ce qui
n'était pas le cas de l'armée qui avait
tant à sa cage aux folles pas du tout ça
du tout au contraire que c'était tout
bon et c'était justement complètement
ouvert et 2 que ce mec-là face aux fines
a été étonnant c'est pour ça que je me
suis dit vas faire mon film parce que il
est il s'intéresse à l'être humain et
s'intéresse aux gens différents et et il
est et il a un besoin de justice en tant
qu' en tant que croyant aussi et au bout
d'un moment on s'est engueulés au début
du film ou du milieu tournage parce
qu'ils avaient ils avaient un peu peur
dans le coin j'en
et quand il a compris ce qu'on faisait
tout ça n'était pas forcément d'accord
avec le film sur l'ensemble mais tel
accord avec avec la philosophie du film
et à un moment il a dit aux journalistes
son avocat quand arrêter de déconner il
l'est bien vécu il l'est mais le décret
que le festival en lui-même et a très
très bien vécu il et il adore ça ils
adorent ça
il a essayé ça lui est donné le feu
juillet il adoré ça il était il était
super en concédant est resté très potes
après même le film n'a pas du tout
marché non l époque heureusement vous
regrettez encore aujourd'hui non non
faut jamais regretter on a dit que
c'était un film gauchistes et c'était le
début sembiosys oui on a dit à l'époque
que c'était un film gauchistes film bat
cité va craquer qui est qui qui date à
peu près qui doit avoir un oud un an ou
deux avant un film gauchistes et est vu
comme un film gauchistes aussi et c'est
le début on sait quoi c'est un film
anarchiste parce qu'un film gauchistes
c'est quoi alors bassit vaincra criaient
c'était ça pour envoyer virginie ledoyen
j'étais terrifié de son beau à ça ça et
on l'a vu comme tel non parce qu
assassin assassin est un film fait pour
deux choses c'est un film de cinéma qui
te qui est fait pour mettre le
spectateur dans une ambiance
cinématographique tendu qui lui rappelle
que le cinéma c'est pas juste de
l'amusement mais c'est aussi c'est aussi
une émotion qui peut être désagréable et
je voulais aussi ramené au dans la tête
du spectateur le fait que la violence
c'est pas c'est c'est pas tarantino la
violence n'est pas tarantino et moi
j'étais extrêmement choqué par le
premier film de tarantino et par tous
les films de tarantino à part parfois
que c'est blanc ou de jacky blanc mais
quand j'ai vu son premier film je me
rappelle très bien j'étais au au cinéma
à pompidou dans les halles et j'ai vu ce
film là et j'entendais les gens
rigolaient pendant les scènes de torture
et je me suis inspiré de revoir dogues
reservoir dogs mais si ça c'est le début
c'est le début de la fin et
effectivement la pop culture a
complètement changé avec ce film lie
avec beaucoup de choses et c'était à une
époque où les choses étaient en train de
changer et quand on rentrait ces films
là dans le zapping
tout d'un coup ils deviennent
complètement décérébrés celle que je
comprends le travail de cinéaste de
d'essayer de debon déjà un cinéaste qui
vole les autres mais bon ça c'est un
autre problème
mais qui essaye de choquer le spectateur
et de l'âme et de le tromper
mais le problème c'est qu'il a profité
de l'époque qui venait avec et ce côté
ce désengagement social complet son
dernier film par exemple sur sur sharon
tate que je suis allé voir sur hollywood
là que je suis allé voir je suis choqué
que avec l'histoire réelle qui s'est
passé qui est une vraie histoire
d'horreur qui s'est passé réellement
avec la femme de roman polanski il est
décidé de partir dans un film d'horreur
ajuste la porte à côté sans retraités
sans traiter aucun sujet je suis choqué
de façon que et d'en tuer hitler avec
une mutuelle à truquer je pense que il
ya beaucoup de choses de jeunes qui
peuvent penser qu'il faille qui n'ont
plus les mêmes références historiques
pour nous on a eu puisqu'il ya tellement
d'influx que ça rentre dans une machine
ou tout à coup on se dit mais ça peut
être aussi la vérité ça peut aussi vous
faites attention vous considérez que le
cinéma valeur d'exemple et qu'il faut
faire attention parce qu'il ya toujours
ces fameux jeunes qu'on imagine toujours
décérébrés ou ignorants à qui faut
expliquer la vraie vie non le sol de
céret bresse et les politiciens les jeux
ne sont jamais décembre les seuls
décérébrés c'est les uniformes c'est ce
qu'ils sont quelques baker boys un
groupe mais les jeunes n'ont jamais
oublié un groupe iso bis à eux mêmes ils
obéissent à ce qu'ils sont par contre si
tu étais ils sont capables de situer non
mais si tu les élèves en leur mettant
des claques dans la gueule mais ils vont
vouloir te mordre la main si tu les
respecte et si tu les situent les
considèrent ils vont être les mêmes gens
que tu es enfant il ya aucune raison que
des mecs des quartiers soient pas comme
tu es enfant tu as bien les ducs étaient
enfants parce qu'ils ont eu de la chance
on a un privilège nous privilège de
blanc qui nous permet d'avoir accès en
france à des choses que que
malheureusement les autres ethnies n'ont
pas et est tout simplement dans le dans
le contact naturel avec les gens dans le
fait de ne pas avoir peur entre blanc de
ne pas avoir peur de l'autre blanc
segrestan sur tarantino parce que c'est
quand même un des seuls sida est un vrai
cinéaste j'entends un complèment qu'on
ne l'aiment pas c'est un vrai cinéaste
et c'est un des seuls qui aujourd'hui
fait rentrer des jeunes justement au
cinéma pour ses films et partant dans le
groupe b sont des taxis 5 aussi
d'intérêt par luc besson justement à ce
moment là on est un peu après
l'essentiel même si même style c'est des
cinéastes qui ne pensent pas à l'impact
qu'ils vont avoir sur le sur leur sur
leur public ils en ont rien à et
c'est pour eux tout est amusant c'est
pas drôle enfin pour moi c'est pas drôle
parce que parce que parce que c'est des
bons
s'il était mauvais encore l'orchestré de
la merde mais ils sont mortelles cdc
décédé ça fait partie des meilleurs
réalisateurs au monde on vous associe
d'ailleurs avec luc besson à l'époque
puisque vous êtes sur le tournage de
chêne dark avec un coup d'oeil
d'ailleurs vous faites des plans tous
les deux vous étiez associés j'ai
toujours été un admirateur de l'udc pour
ses films et sa qualité de réalisateur
sont son savoir-faire puisse aussi un
mec qui s'est fait tout seul et ses
parents étaient gelés au club med donc
il s'est inventé le cinéma tout seul et
c'est inventer un cinéma complètement
pas j'ai toujours aimé ça par contre
j'ai toujours eu des problèmes avec avec
les sujets des films avec la façon dont
ils le traitent avec cette violence est
ce que ces films qui l'écrit produit que
c'est ce collège lui même nom même ceux
qui réalisent jeunes nikita est un film
qui me choque je peux exposer enfin le
même mois en tant que cinéaste et
j'arriverai pas exposer mais j'ai une
enfant autant de je ne savais pas partie
de mon concept social mais ces mets donc
j'ai des problèmes avec certains
réalisateurs certains films avec
certains artistes qui pour moi sortes de
mets ça c'est des questions très
personnelles d'éthique personnelle qui
n'ont rien à voir avec avec l'art entend
quartier je les trouve absolument
incroyable
mais humainement une casse les couilles
justement parce que j'ai trouvé
incroyable en tant qu'artiste je me dis
mais pourquoi t'es pas humble l'être
humain quoi tu vois c'est comme céline
tu as envie de le situer rencontre j'ai
envie de dire mais pourquoi tout est
enfin pourquoi tu es un nazi tu veux pas
faire des choses aussi belges en parle
avec mon père l'autre jour
je dis mais qu'est ce que tu peux
considérer quelqu'un qui écrit des
choses aussi belle mais qui écrit des
choses aussi horribles
tu vas donc il faut bon on va pas
considéré excuse moi mais d'un autre
côté il ya un côté un petit peu faut
faire attention parce que ça lui ferait
ça une vraie influence sur les gens
vraiment ça infuse
au fur et à mesure du temps ça influe
sur les gens et et la carrière
magnifique d'un mec comme comme
tarantino influence énormément de gens
influences d'autres cinéastes à changer
complètement notre rapport à la violence
au cinéma complet aujourd'hui peut plus
y avoir un film dans une fusillade dans
la rue fusillade qui n'a jamais existé
dans la réalité par exemple oui non si
oui c'est même pire que ça parce que les
fusillades qui n'est que je ne verrai
jamais existé dans la rue existait avant
les films de tantine la fusillade entre
gangsters qui viennent qui viennent
sinon tu inventes il a rendu l'âme l'a
rendu banal pur comme un art martial
asiatiques et et s'inspire directement
des films asiatiques pour ça que soit
jeune ou avec ses façons braquer les
gens aux cetc ces choses là mais les
idées qu'il a sur ce nom génial mais et
je trouve moi que j'ai deux dans les
rigoles je m'amuse mais quand je sors du
cinéma je me dis qu'est ce que j'ai
appris qu'est ce que j'ai appris sur moi
sur la société est ce que je vois de la
société à travers ce film ne me plaît
pas c'est qu'on achetait les gens qui
l'aiment bien tantinet ses meilleurs
c'est un des meilleurs réalisateurs un
des meilleurs cinéastes un des meilleurs
écrivains mais si je l'étais en face de
moi je dis mais le mec mais ton talent
un de sujets que ça serve la
société quoi en tout cas si tu prends un
sujet de société ne le détourne pas en
pour en faire une comédie avec des gens
qui brûlent dans des piscines par lot de
ballons des rivières pourpres qui est
votre quatrième film en tant que
réalisateur qui va être un énorme succès
plus de 3 millions de de spectateurs la
même année d'ailleurs sort le pacte des
loups de christophe gans
qui lui fait plus de 5 millions les deux
sont interprétés par vincent cassel
las un vrai basculement dans le cinéma
français on revient au cinéma de genre
c'est la fin des années 90 terrible où
tous les films s'appelait la fille seule
je m'ennuie ans et non vous n'allez pas
cet appareil a part ça le et les loups
le film de gand s'il y avait quoi
après il ya eu d'autres mais quoi quoi
mais il ya eu un retour au film de genre
à bomber a forcément réussie avec
quelques ailes film de genre d'action un
peu grand spectacle avec de la mise en
scène avec du du costume avec de
l'ambition
quel autre film ont existé ça et vous et
ont même créé très peu mais il n'y a
toujours pas aujourd'hui il n'y aura
toujours pas aujourd'hui
montre moi un film aujourd'hui français
qui a une ambition de 2,2
cinématographique tout simplement oui
c'est c'est de moins en moins même bien
vu on n'a jamais eu mais à ce moment-là
ça libère une envie on peut refaire du
cinéma de genre on peut faire des films
coraux avait plein d'amis du toit par
exemple on essayait sont faits les
rivières pourpres 2 et 3 que la merde
oui ils sont pas ce qu'ils ont dit oui
mais non mais non non non c'est le
travail parce que tu pompe le pognon des
gens parce que tu sais qu'ils vont
rentrer parce que tu arrives tu à une
licence mais si tu fais bien le travail
comme fait back to the future deux bacs
de déchets sur trois qui sont ô des
films aussi intéressant que le premier
où les terminator ou les films ou les
mecs chaque fois se disent bon comment
on va faire mieux que la prochaine la
fois l'avant et ça c'est moi j'admire ça
quand je vais voir ces films là de deux
franchises les marvel génie mais bon les
marvel ce autre chose parce que là on
est passé dans le digital maintenant
c'est juste du concubin du calcul mais à
l'époque où il fallait faire
11 et l'ailé et les indiana jones les
mecs se casser le cul
comment faire mieux que celui d'avant
parce qu'on prenait spectateurs pour
quelqu'un d'intelligent et surtout on
voulait se faire plaisir et en france on
n'a jamais vu ça je me souviens d'alain
de greef à canal plus qui avait beaucoup
milité justement notamment pour en
faveur de de gaspar noé mais pas
seulement pour un retour à un cinéma
français ambitieux qui intéresse le
spectateur parce qu'il se plaignait
toujours que les films français
bien que les abonnés de canal+ les avais
déjà avait déjà payé pour les voir il
les regardait peu
quand il passait en crypté sur canal +
et ils voient dans ces deux films là
dedans ce moment là le ds ayela quelque
chose va se débloquer on va de nouveau
pouvoir faire des films comme ça vous
allez voir ce qu'on en a pas fait non
parce qu'ils avaient pas les cinéastes
derrière oui il ya christophe mois yann
gaspard j'en oublie de trois peut-être
eric est encore eric il n'est pas parti
dans ce genre de finir par dupontel dans
un autre genre dupontel dans un autre
genre parce que aussi bien évidemment
pas oublié jean pierre jeunet
mais on est un tout petit groupe et on
fait on fait des films on fait un film
tous les trois en quatre ans donc c'est
pas assez pour faire pour faire une
vague quoi et puis et puis surtout jean
pierre jeunet a des problèmes pour
trouver de l'argent pour faire ces films
quand il a fait heureusement il avait
des produits d'une productrice admirable
quand il a fait la cité des enfants
perdus et tous ces films là mais ça
n'arrive qu'une fois dans sa vie c'est
très rare de pouvoir faire se sortir ce
truc il y avait c'était un peu pour moi
il y avait leos carax d'un côté avec son
film ce qui est de l'autre côté tu as vu
les mecs qui qu'il y avait qui avait une
vraie raison d'avoir un vrai budget
parce qu est-ce qui est créé un univers
complètement différents et pour les
fantasmagories rien je devais qui vous
tourner de la fabuleuse fabuleux destin
d'amélie poulain qui devient un succès
énorme
mondial celui là vous allez partir aux
etats-unis faire d'abord gothika puis
puis babylone et 10 gothika ça se passe
pas trop mal c'est bah ouais et babylon
a dit très très belle revanche ouais
ouais ouais ouais ouais non je suis
parti après assassin je suis parti parce
que bon je vous avais fait mon tour je
me suis dit j'avais fait un truc
ailleurs et j'avais des gros projets là
bas je voulais faire des trucs assez
ambitieux qui en fait en étant là bas je
me suis rendu compte que c'était pas
trop mon univers et je suis pas trop
capable de faire les concessions qui il
demande par contrat avec trois avocats
sur le dos au moment où tu signes et je
me suis j'ai jamais réussi à m'engager
complètement dans des projets j'ai eu
plein de projets intéressants mais plein
de choses que j'avais pas envie de faire
et et je me suis et puis par hasard je
me suis retrouvé justement à cause des
rivières pourpres qui passait dans un
avion dans lequel était un producteur
qui venait faire la fête en france après
avoir fait la fête il m'a appelé je suis
passé dans sa suite ml je tourne dans
deux mois j'ai lé berry j'ai fais ok
c'est égotique ça s'appelle un film de
commande je n'avais jamais fait de film
de commande et c'est un film on te donne
le scénario on te donne des comptes
donne ton budget on te dire que les
rivières pop c'est un film vous montrer
une très grande maîtrise
professionnellement
le film est impeccable et en même temps
vous conservez votre style attendre pour
les producteurs mais moi j'ai un style
j'ai un site de mise en scène qui est
très très très adéquat pour ses bourdes
et pour les films de pour les films de
rythme
c'est à dire ça c'est un thriller
d'horreur avec tous les moments de
d'attentes de suspense pour le killer
mais c'est un film de serial killer donc
poussé moment on tourne autour d'un
objet qu'est ce qui se passe derrière
moi j'adore trouver le rythme de la
caméra et retrouver le sommet ça fait
partie de mon cinéma puis moi c'est j'ai
complètement grandi là dessus en tout
les carpenter tous les tout le cinéma
américain des années 80 je suis passé à
travers
pourquoi ça se passe mal babyloan heidi
parce que j'avais un parce que j'avais
un bon on peut mettre les choses sur moi
mais mon analyse à moi et j'avais très
mal entouré je me suis j'avais un bon
projet un film qui au jeudi
faut qu'il soit aliments il faut qu'il
soit financé 30% fin c'est la perception
d'un roman de marie dantec
il faut savoir que parfois on commence
montech pour ceux qui ne savent pas à
les googlers dantec sauvera plaisir il
est mort depuis le pauvre mais c'était
un personnage assez intéressant et très
très très controverse j'étais étonnée
d'arriver à mettre ce film-là en
scénario est ensuite d'arriver à le
faire financer et ensuite d'arriver à
trouver une star comme ville disent
elles donc j'étais sur un petit nuage en
disant waouh c'est en train de passer
parce que le film est quand même un film
assez fort sur la société parle de la
part de quelque chose de très sérieux et
je vous dise en train de passer personne
ne voit le truc mais en fait pour que ça
passe est obligé de m'associer à des
gens qui étaient un peu des imbéciles et
donc vindis elle est en tête creuse
comme dit oui enfin bon ils ressemblent
à venizel quoi j'étais associé un
producteur français qui n'avaient aucune
à au toujours aucun intérêt dans le
cinéma qui aiment que pour le aller
fumer des cigares et gagner de l'argent
et avec le studio américain le pire de
l'époque avec les pires trucs les mecs
les plus horribles j'ai eu des mecs qui
nous truc tout laisse toutes les scènes
que tu peux imaginer de tutorat tu vas
te trouvais j'avais travaillé dans ces
lieux et tout est donc j'étais associé à
ces trois personnes et j'essaie de faire
le film au milieu et le film a été mal
budgétés et on m'a dit au bout de trois
semaines de tournage qui a eu plus
d'argent pour faire le film tandis que
moi j'étais dans mon temps et tout ça
donc j'essaie de m'en sortir
les producteurs sont venus les les
assureurs américains sont venus ils ont
viré le producteur ils ont épuise
ils ont voulu me virer et en fait ils
m'ont demandé de rester pour leur aider
pour les aider à faire le film finir le
film ville disent elle a voulu reprendre
la mise en scène du film il a réalisé
deux jours moi j'étais à côté je
rigolais c'était complètement fou ce qui
est possible c'est infini en france ce
serait plus dur c'est arrivé mais en
général le réalisateur gagner à la fin
non en france tu peux pas parce qu'en
france on a le on a le droit moral sur
le sur les tout ce qui est la propriété
intellectuelle donc si je suis l'auteur
de mon sujet même si c'est toi qui
produit mais c'est moi qui elle ferait
le final cut
par contre tu as les problèmes aux
tournages oui parce que des acteurs qui
veulent pas faire ce que tu veux parce
que tu as des problèmes d'argent tu as
des trucs comme ça mais là c'était un
truc c'était protocolaire et s'étaient
tous les matins
des messages de deux des avocats du raid
de trucs des machins lanctôt c'était
j'étais là au milieu un truc bien
documents qu'il faut absolument voir sur
ce film s'appelle fucking kassovitz
c'est sur youtube
c'est un document qu'on a réuni mois et
le jeune homme qui faisait le making of
qui étaient là pendant le tournage qui
disaient qu'est ce qu'on fait et je
faisais ben on va écoute je pense que le
making off va être plus intéressant que
le film donc gardons les images on n'a
pas pu tout monter parce que sinon on
aurait eu des procès mais on a monté des
trucs assez intéressant et de documents
il a complètement fou sur comment ne pas
faire un film
un mot sur l'ordre et la morale qui est
votre dernier film en date en tant que
cinéaste c'était en 2011 c'est sur la
prise d'otages d'ouvéa en 1988
c'est un film que moi j'avais trouvé
extrêmement bien réussi et qui n'a pas
du tout marché et je me souviens qu'on
avait fait une émission ensemble pour la
sortie c'était dans ce soir ou jamais à
l'époque sur france télévisions il y
avait d'ailleurs tous les protagonistes
du film il y avait la réponse l'ancien
ministre il y avait le le garçon dont
vous interpréter le rôle tout le monde
était là
pas d'accord d'ailleurs sur le film
semaine n'a pas du tout marché il
n'intéressait pas les tgv s'éclate à une
somme jamais si je me suis très aimé ou
pas me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait
un problème quand on était sur le
plateau avec toi et que j'avais pons et
ce général quatre étoiles qui étaient là
qui disait que le film était un mensonge
et je leur ai demandé de me citer de me
pointer les mensonges et ils m'ont dit
tous les nous ont dit à l'écran tous les
deux qu'ils n'avaient pas vu le film et
pons qui est responsable de la mort de
tous ces gens et qui a été là qu'ils
étaient même même s'il ne se sent pas
responsable devrait juste avoir la
curiosité d'aller voir le film pour
pouvoir débattre pouvoir en débattre
pour pouvoir juste se défendre ou pour
juste par curiosité ou pour même pas par
par empathie parce qu'il ya eu des morts
donc même si on manque essaye de
comprendre le sujet et se refilent ce
rejet là et et le fait que personne n'en
a rien à que c'est de ces deux
hommes
ces deux hauts gradés ou c'est aux
politiciens sont en train de mentir à
moi puisqu'ils n'ont pas vu le film et
qu'il juge sans savoir je me suis dit un
problème les gens n'ont plus rien à
et je pense qu'on en est arrivé à
une époque où les gens n'auraient plus
rien à et vous vous en avais plus
rien à de la réalisation vous
n'avez plus envie de réaliser des films
en danger toujours très envie de
réaliser les films mais j'en ai plus
rien à d'essayer de sauver le
monde
je pense que le monde est ce qu'il est
et qu' il s'en sortira très bien sans
moi et je pense aussi qu'en tant
qu'acteur vous êtes très épanouie avec
le bureau des légendes vous avez souvent
dit que le métier d'acteur c'est un
métier de fainéant mais le bureau des
légions de j'ai l'impression que ça vous
épanouie quoi ma le bureau de légende et
a un rôle de fainéant par excellence
puisque il ya beaucoup de personnages
ont adressé dans la série et que
on les suit tous donc quand on en suit
un ben moi je suis pas sur le tournage
donc je suis chez moi et c'est un
personnage qui est magnifique mais qui
est basée sur le fait de ne pas
transmettre ses émotions
donc pour moi c'était un plaisir à jouer
de laisser le spectateur s'inventer sont
ce qui se passe dans ma tête et c'était
un personnage absolument génial que
j'espère qu'on va encore profiter
pendant une prochaine saison aussi eric
envie de remettre de rona t.ron quand on
dit que c'est jacques audiard qui
réalisera la prochaine saison
jacques audiard avec qui vous avez
souvent tournées qui a jamais entendu
parler de ça ah bon non mais moi j'avais
cru comprendre qu'ils réalisaient les
deux derniers 10 réalisent les deux
démos l'aide d'eric rochant l'année lire
elle mais je pense que si vous avez posé
la question à je connais il va vous dire
lieu d'écouté je crois que c'est un peu
trop de travail parce que c'est un très
très bon travail il faut être sûr que
pour arriver à faire le bureau des
légendes
il faut il faut être complètement
intégré à son sujet 24 heures sur 24 et
ne penser à rien d'autre
si c'est pas fort société pas ta passion
tu peux pas eric a passé cinq ans à
passer finir une série faire une saison
et pendant qu'il était en train de
monter cinq épisodes en même temps était
en train de commencer à écrire la saison
prochaine et ce à tous les ans pendant
cinq ans et il s'arrêtait avant de
devenir fou que ça a donné
pratiquement la seule série française
qui est au niveau des séries anglaises
ou américaines
enfin qu'est ou au niveau des autres
séries je sais pas mais en tout cas
c'est une bonne série
c'est une série encore une fois c'est
toujours même principe
au cinéma il ya deux cinémas il ya le
cinéma qui t'amuse et qui n'a pas besoin
d'être fait avec véritablement beaucoup
de l'intelligence ou d'élégance
parce qu'il est là pour remplir un
espace et puis un cinéma qui est fait
par décident pas des gens qui veulent
véritablement échanger des informations
et faire passer des idées des concepts
qui ne sont pas forcément que auquel tu
n'as pas accès qui se servent du cinéma
un peu com de com des médias
d'information
et j'ai la chance d'avoir travaillé avec
beaucoup de réalisateurs qui se
servaient de ce à quoi
merci mathieu kassovitz d'avoir passé
toute cette émission avec nous je
rappelle que l'aisne fait 105 25e
anniversaire et font salle et fête son
25ème anniversaire aussi au palais de
tokyo à partir de début septembre
dans une exposition qu'on fait avec les
colts kourtrajmé avec la jelly justement
jr et tous les toutous ce que ce film a
pu inspirer tous que là il n'a pu
inspirer à cette jeune génération qui
avait 10 ans à l'époque
ils ont tous fait une représentation de
ce que ça représente pour eux
aujourd'hui voilà et ce sera ensuite en
dvd en 4k bien entendu qui arrive très
bientôt et bientôt et les dessous merci
et rendez vous au prochain numéro
à bientôt
[Musique]